lui voit la kabylie bonjour nous avons
concédé travailler avec ces deux là
n'ont ni honneur un plaisir j'ai
tellement appris la vérité aux français
ils sont durs très durs
[Rires]
comment ça s'est passé comment comment
comment vous êtes retrouvés tous
ensemble
à marseille on a vécu ensemble à
marseille pendant deux mois et
voilà c'était très c'était convivial
c'était studieux c'était joyeux
je pense que tom à venir s'installer en
france
oui weiss et elle vous a donné des
conseils vis-à-vis de comment vous
comporter comme en français non je suis
nul en français tu le sais bien dédié
mais fait de travailler camille je
n'avais qu'un lézard gratter et j'étais
instantanément dans le la scène je suis
très fier cette chimie on voulait créer
un rapport de vous et personne qui
venait de d'endroits différents qui se
retrouvent et je suis vraiment ravi avec
les résultats et c'est grâce à elle je
dois vous libérer puisque vous avez un
tapis rouge à parcourir
merci beaucoup à demain on va voir
[Musique]